Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin die die Stabende Ärztin auf der Station und würde gerne das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen. Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja Frau Doktor.
Ok, so als werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen. Danach können wir Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Und wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin Hans Kovermann.
Hans Kovermann?
Ja.
Ok, Herr Kovermann, können Sie Ihren Fonds nachnehmen?
Hans Kovermann.
Ok, ich verstehe. Und wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin 52, Frau Doktor.
52, ok. Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
3. März 1973.
1973, ok. Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, ich bin 1 Meter 61.
61?
Ja.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, ungefähr 61 Kilogramm.
61, ok.
Frau Doktor, sind Sie Assistenärztin oder Aufhehrerin?
Nein, ich habe keine.
Ich würde gerne mit Oberarzt sprechen. Gibt es Möglichkeiten?
Ja, natürlich.
Sie sehen sehr jung aus. Haben Sie Erfahrung?
Ja, ich habe viel Erfahrung. Und ich bin nicht sehr jung.
Und ich verstehe Ihre Wünsche. Aber ich möchte sagen,
ich muss sagen, wenn Sie meinen Oberarzt besprechen möchten,
müssen Sie eine Stunde oder mehr warten.
Aber nach dem ersten Gespräch werde ich Ihre Wünsche
meinem Oberarzt besprechen. Und alle Entscheidungen werden
zusammengetroffen. Bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Ok, Frau Doktor. Ich verstehe.
Danke schön für diese Informationen und Ihre Verständnis.
Und ich möchte weitergehen. Ok?
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Frau Susanne Thür.
Thür.
Ok, ich verstehe. Und was für Sie heute so ist?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Oder wie können wir Ihnen helfen?
Frau Doktor, ehrlich gesagt habe ich Beinschmerzen.
Ich fühle meinen Bein schmerzhaft. Und ich kann nicht gut laufen jetzt.
Ich habe gewartet, aber meine Beschwerden sind seit 3 Tagen
schmerzhaft. Ich möchte jetzt in das Krankenhaus kommen und besuchen.
Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, Herr Kovermann.
Und können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben? Sind Sie krank oder dumm?
Oder sind Sie schmerzhaft?
Ja, es gibt ein Druckgefühl in meinem rechten Bein.
Und wie sind Sie schmerzhaft?
Sie sind schmerzhaft.
Ja, ja.
Und wie sind Ihre Schmerzen aufgetreten?
Könnten Sie etwas sagen?
Ja, plötzlich. Vor 3 Tagen, vor 2 Tagen kann ich sagen.
Plötzlich, aber schlimm geworden. Seit gestern schlimm geworden.
Ok. Ist jetzt Ihr Bein gerotet oder geschwollen und überwacht?
Ja, ja. Ein bisschen wärmer als der andere Bein.
Und ein bisschen nicht rot, aber ein bisschen pink.
Röter als der andere Bein auch.
Und ein bisschen dick geworden. Mein Socken hat Druck in meinem Bein.
Ok. Haben Sie jetzt Schmerzen?
Ja, ja habe ich Schmerzen.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10, wobei ein sehr lauter 10 sehr stark Schmerzen erspringt?
Ja, nicht sehr schlimm, aber 5 oder 6.
5 oder 6. Ok.
Strennen Sie Schmerzen in irgendwelchen Körperteilen aus, zum Beispiel Fuß oder Leisten?
Ja, ich habe Schmerzen in der Wade und strelle Kniekehle und auch Oberschenkel.
Mein Schmerzen strelt Oberschenkel aus.
Ok. Denken Sie, es gibt eine bestimmte Auslösung für Ihre Schmerzen?
Nein, das ist nicht produkt.
Ok. Sind Ihre Schmerzen beim Bewerbungen oder Belastungen oder eine Lageposition verschlimmert oder verbessert?
Ich kann nicht belasten jetzt. Ich muss immer berühren. Kann ich nicht belasten oder gut laufen?
Ok. Ja, ich verstehe.
Könnten Sie Ihre Beine abholen oder strecken?
Wenn ich strecke, dann tut das weh, aber ich kann nicht gut beugen. Wenn ich hoch lege, dann geht das besser.
Ok. Ich verstehe. Haben Sie überhaupt?
Ich fühle mich nicht, Frau Doktor. Ich fühle mich müde, aber ich fühle mich nicht febri.
Ok. Ist Ihnen übel oder haben Sie Erbrechen?
Ja, heute Morgen habe ich ein bisschen Übereinheit.
Ok. Haben Sie für Ihre Schmerzen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Nein, habe ich nicht eingenommen, Frau Doktor.
Ok. Waren Sie beim Hausarzt für Ihre Schmerzen?
Seit zwei Tagen habe ich Schmerzen. So komme ich sofort. Ja, das erste Mal.
Ok. Ist Ihnen schwindelig? Nein, nein.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ok. Haben Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten ungewöhnlich ab oder so genommen?
Nein, ich bin immer 60 ungefähr.
Ok. Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, ich schlafe nicht gut, Frau Doktor. Aber das ist eine lange Geschichte.
Meine Arbeit ist sehr stressig und deswegen schlafe ich nicht gut.
Ok. Was machen Sie Berufli?
Ich bin Manager. Geschäftsführer. Das ist sehr stressig, Frau Doktor.
Ich reise immer. Reisen? Ja, ins Ausland und zurückkommen.
Letzte Woche war ich in Brasilien und vor drei Tagen fliege ich zurück.
Ich bin zurückgeflogen und ich bin immer unterwegs.
Ok. Wie lange dauert Ihr letzter Flug?
Von Brasilien nach Deutschland? Ja. Ungefähr acht Stunden.
Acht Stunden. Ok.
Haben Sie früher 55 Jahre lang gehabt? Nein, das war erst mal.
Ist Ihnen eine Gefäßerkrankung bekannt?
Gefäßerkrankung? Vor zehn Jahren wurde ich wegen Kranfada operiert.
Kranfada? Ja. War das komplikationlos?
Ja, das war gut. Ich hatte kein Problem.
Ok. Und haben Sie Hüsten oder Atemnot?
Ja, ich Hüste. Seit wann?
Seit ein Jahr. Das Hüsten ist immer problematisch für mich.
Rachen Sie? Ja, natürlich. Gerne.
Wie viel rachen Sie? 30 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Seit wann rachen Sie? Seit 20 Leben.
20 Jahre vielleicht. Ok. Und haben Sie Atemnot?
Jetzt? Ja, manchmal habe ich Probleme mit Atem.
Wenn ich besonders steige, reicht mein Atem nicht.
Aber das ist auch eine lange Geschichte. Seit zwei Jahren habe ich Atemnot.
Haben Sie ein Brustgefühl?
Manchmal habe ich Brustgefühl. Seit drei Tagen?
Nein, jetzt nicht.
Ok. Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstorben oder Herzklopfen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Sturgang?
Ja, ich gehe immer ums Klo zum Wasser lassen. Einmal. Und ich habe chronische Verstöpfung.
Wann hast du eine Verstöpfung?
Das ist chronisch. Gestern hatte ich eine, aber ein oder zwei Mal pro Woche.
Ein oder zwei Mal pro Woche.
Das ist immer problematisch. Verstöpfung, Wasserlassen. Viele verschiedene Probleme.
Viele chronische Probleme. Wissen Sie schon?
Sie sind nicht so alt.
Danke Frau Doktor. Ich habe viele Probleme.
Haben Sie irgendwelche chronischen Krankheiten?
Ich habe seit 15 Jahren Blutdruck. Seit 14 Jahren habe ich eine Zuckerkrankheit.
14 Jahre?
Ja, das war Typ 1 Diabetes.
Mein Herz ist schwach. Mein Kardiolog hat mir gesagt, dass mein Herz schwach ist.
Deswegen nehme ich manchmal Medikamente. Herzschwache habe ich auch.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Viele. Metaprolol nehme ich 25 mg. Und ein Wassertablette. Was heißt?
Tiaktasid. 12,5 mg.
Und Insulinepumpe habe ich. Ich nehme immer Insuline-Splitz.
Und gegen Verstöpfung nehme ich Tropfen.
Kennen Sie die Namen dieser Tropfen? Nein, das kenne ich nicht.
Seit wann haben Sie oder ist bei Ihnen? Wann hast du Herzschwache?
Seit 2 oder 3 Jahren. Ich kann nicht Sport treiben. Ich fühle mich immer müde.
Nehmen Sie noch etwas? Sie nehmen Metaprolol zweimal täglich?
Ja, zweimal. Einmal morgen, einmal abends nehme ich.
Nehmen Sie Tiakasid? Zweimal.
Und Sie benutzen Insuline und Tropfen. Würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, einmal. Wegen Krampfaden. Vor 10 Jahren. In beiden Beinen.
Und gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronischen Erkrankungen?
Leider ist mein Vater an Herzinfarkt gestorben. Vor 7 Jahren.
Und meine Mutter ist leider auch an Zuckerkrankheit gestorben.
Ist das erblich? Ja, Leider ist Diabetes Melutus eine Erblich-Krankheit.
Aber meine Mutter nimmt nicht Insuline. Ich nehme Insuline.
Ja, das ist erblich. Aber meine Mutter hat eine unterschiedliche Diabetes Melutus.
Das ist eine Erwachsene Diabetes. Erwachsene Zuckerkrankheit.
Okay, haben Sie Gechüßung? Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund? Ja, sie ist ganz gesund.
Okay, trinken Sie auch Alkohol? Ja, manchmal trinke ich Rotwein.
Rotwein ist gesund Frau Doktor. Leider trinke ich ein Glas Rotwein.
Ja, das trinke ich. Jede Woche.
Herr Kobermann, Sie haben viele Erzikafaktoren für viele Erkrankungen.
Und Alkohol ist ein Erzikafaktor. Deshalb kann ich leider nicht sagen, Alkohol ist gesund für Sie.
Okay. Und haben Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, niemals.
Sind Sie verheiratet? Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder? Ja, zwei Kinder. Sie sind gesund.
Okay. Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeit?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergie.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft? Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Okay, Herr Kobermann, ich habe meine allerwichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Und möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen, das wissen Sie?
Ja, natürlich, Frau Doktor. Ich frage mich darauf, was habe ich?
Was kann ich haben? Ich habe Angst, natürlich. Mein Vater ist wegen einer Herzerkrankung gestorben.
Und ja, ich habe Angst.
Okay, Herr Kobermann, ich kann Ihre Angst sehr gut verstehen.
Aber Sie müssen sich nicht Sorgen machen.
Sie können viele Ursachen haben. Deshalb kann ich Ihnen leider noch keine Antwort geben.
Um eine eindeutige Diagnose zu stellen, müssen wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Sobald die Ergebnisse vorliegen, kann ich Ihnen genauer sagen.
Aber es gibt keine Grund für Angst oder Sorgen.
Unser Team ist sehr qualifiziert und erfahren.
Und wir werden alle nötigen Untersuchungen durchführen.
Und ich werde Sie Schritt-by-Schritt informieren.
Vielen Dank Frau Doktor. Vielen Dank.
Jetzt werden wir die
Korporationen durchführen und einige Operationen durchführen.
Bitte nehmen Sie sich in Vartezima Platz.
Nein.
Nehmen Sie Platz, ja.
Bitte nehmen Sie Platz in Vartezima. Und eine Schwester kümmert sich um Sie.
Okay.
Gut.
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen. Haben Sie Kürsat für mich?
Ja, ich bitte schon.
Okay. Der Patient heißt Hans Kovermann, ist 42 Jahre alt, 1,61 Meter groß und wiegt 1,60 Kilogramm.
Herr Kovermann stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit drei Tagen bestehender Zunehmender.
Der Rechseitiger, Rechseitiger, Starker, durkende, durkende, siehende,
plötzlich aufgetreten, schmerzen im Rechtebein vor.
Der Patient berichtet, dass ihre Schmerzen nach einem langen Reise aufgetreten sind.
Und er berichtet, dass ihr Bein jetzt, und er habe bei ihrem Bein eine Schwierigkeit überwacht.
Welche Fachbegriffe benutzt du mir?
Okay.
Der Patient hat die Beine des Patienten.
Die Beine des Patienten haben die Beine von Dollar und Rubor.
Okay.
Ja, Rubor. Und der Patient hat die Bewegung eingeschränkt mit Beugen oder Strehen.
Und in der vegetativen Anamnese ergab Neusea heute Morgen und Insomni.
Der Patient hat auch Hüsten und Dyspne, aber diese Beschwerden haben lange Zeit.
Und der Patient klagt auch über Nocturi und Verstorben.
Der Patient hat seit 15 Jahren Arterieleiparton.
Und seit 14 Jahren Diabetes Meliopstibs.
Und seit drei Jahren Herzinsuffizienz.
Und er nimmt regelmäßig Metallprolole, 25 mg zweimal täglich,
und Insulinpumpe benutzen.
Zweimal täglich ein. Und er benutze Insulinpumpe.
Und er hat Verstorbenheit und dagegen...
Obstipation können wir sagen.
Ja, Obstipation. Und er benutze dagegen eine Trophä.
Und der Patient würde seit vor zehn Jahren...
Welche Trophä benutzt ihr gegen Obstipation? Wissen Sie?
Nein. Und er hat die Namen der Medikamente nicht erinnert.
Aber ich kann die Medikamentenliste schauen.
Oder Hausarzt kann fragen.
Hat der Patient eine Medikamentenliste dabei?
Haben Sie schon gefragt?
Ich habe nicht gefragt, aber während der Untersuchung kann ich fragen.
Okay, machen Sie weiter bitte.
Okay. Und der Patient seit vor zehn Jahren eine Barikoseoperation durchgeführt werden.
Okay.
Er hat seit 20 Jahren 30 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Und er trinkt ein Glas Rotwein jede Woche pro Woche.
Er trinkt ein Glas Rotwein jede Woche.
Er hat keine Sportaufgaben, Müdigkeit oder Herzinsuffizienz.
Er ist verheiratet, hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Und er arbeitet als Medikament.
Er hat keine bekannten Allergien.
Und er ist vollständig geimpft.
Und er war vor drei Tagen in Brasilien.
Okay.
Und die Analyse des Angebetens an die Ärzte.
TvT.
Und als Differenz.
Was ist TvT denn?
Tiefe bei Venenthrombosen.
Tiefe Venenthrombosen.
Welche Symptome sprechen für eine TvT bei diesen Patienten?
Okay.
Die Erkrankungen oder die Erkrankungen vorgegeben.
Neuere Kosen zum Beispiel.
Und Nikotinkonsum.
Und die Symptome gerotet, geschwollen und überwärmt.
Weil sprich für eine Tiefe Venenthrombosen.
Okay.
Als Differenz.
Die Diagnosen kommen.
P.A.V.K. und Varikose.
Und ein Elisipel in Betracht.
Sollten sich die Verdacht Diagnose oder.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen.
Ja.
Sollten die folgenden Maßnahmen durchgeführt werden.
Zuerst werde ich beim Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Dann Blut abnehmen.
Und die Parameter bestimmen lassen.
Dann werde ich weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Beweite ich die Substanz von Beinen.
Und ich beurteile beide Beine.
Dann.
Ich parpiere die Peripheralpuls.
Am Bein.
Und.
Ja.
Welche Zeichen.
Wissen Sie.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Ich meine.
Bei TVT.
Welche Zeichen.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht.
Parameze.
Okay.
Ja.
Die Beine hochlagen.
Und der Patient habe Schmerzen im Leistungsbereich.
Nein.
Das ist nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie schon Paierzeichen oder Meyerzeichen oder Homenzeichen gehört?
Ja.
Ich habe gehört.
Aber ich kann nicht erklären.
Diese Zeichen.
Mit meinem Deutsch.
Okay.
Machen Sie weiter.
Und.
Laboruntersuchungen würde ich einige Laborparameter wie.
Großes Blut mit Entzündung Parameter.
Nieren und Leberwerte.
Und einige Elektrolytus.
Und.
Das ist nicht meine.
Das war nicht meine.
Lieferanzei.
Aber ich möchte.
Die Dimension.
Veranlassen.
Um die Lungenembolie.
Auszuschließen.
Und.
Also die mehr Werte sind auch sehr wichtig.
Bei TV.
Also Sie haben recht.
Die sollen diese Werte.
Auf jeden Fall kontrollieren.
Genau.
Ich möchte auch.
Geronim.
Parameter.
Veranlassen.
Dann.
Ich.
Würde eine.
Sonografie.
Der hier.
Eine Beinssonografie.
Oder.
Eigentlich nicht.
Meaning.
Doppler.
Sonografie.
Veranlassen.
Und die.
Meine.
meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen.
Dann gegebenenfalls aber nein.
Sie haben schon ihre Verdacht Diagnose bestätigt.
Welche Möglichkeiten haben wir?
Okay, sollte sich die Verdacht Diagnose bestätigen,
dann schlage ich die folgende Therapie vor.
Ich würde zuerst meinen Patienten stationär aufnehmen,
dann den Allgemeinen Zustand stabilisieren
und ich würde Antikorgelant-Therapie beginnen,
zum Beispiel mit Heparin.
Also Bettruhe oder Mobilisierung?
In diesem Fall empfehle ich die Mobilisierung
mit Kompression-Therapie.
Kompressionsstrumpfe.
Haben wir auch eine operative Behandlung methodisch?
Wenn der Patient keine Besserung hat
oder eine schlimmste Fall vorliegt,
dann können wir eine Operation planen.
Aber zuerst würde ich eine Allgemeine Struktur konzentrieren.
Allgemeine Struktur oder Antikorgel?
Okay, was sagen sie hier?
Herzgefäße.
Herzchirurgie.
Welche Risikofaktoren kennen Sie Frau Doktor bei TFT?
Der erste Risikofaktor ist lange Reise.
Generell Risikofaktoren, nicht für diese Patienten.
Okay, einige.
Nikotinabus.
Manchmal auch alte.
Die sitzen lange Zeit.
Einige vor Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Arteriella,
Hypertonie oder Diabetes mellitus, besonders Typ 1.
Der Patient hat auch in diesem Fall Herzinsuffizienz
und Erblichbelastung.
Das sind Risikofaktoren für TFT.
Vadykosis, länger Immobilität,
Nikotinabus und weibliches Geschlecht,
Hormon-Ersatztherapie,
Operationen wie TEP,
Total Endoprothese zum Beispiel.
Adiposität ist auch sehr wichtig.
Okay, was sind die Unterschiede zwischen TFT und PAVK?
PAVK ist eine Venoserkrankung,
aber PAVK ist eine Arteriellaerkrankung.
Das ist das wichtigste.
Bei der Inspektion zum Beispiel.
Was sind die Unterschiede zwischen diesen Erkrankungen?
Das ist eine Venoserkrankung mit geradet überwarmen Symptomen.
Aber PAVK ist eine Arteriellaerkrankung mit Symptomen wie kalte Beine,
Blase und kalte Beine.
Okay, wir haben schon über alles gesprochen.
Labor, körperliche Untersuchung, TFT, Therapie.
Es gibt viele Fragen bei diesen Erkrankungen, aber das ist genug, ich glaube.
Wir haben nicht weiter Zeit. Meine Berufung ist beendet.
Okay, mein Chefarzt.